oh look what time of year it is oh it's
the best time of year it's the time to
talk about some really horrible movies
that I really didn't like some films
that I really couldn't stand seeing
films I went to the theater and I
thought to myself why do I do this I
questioned humanity I questioned my love
of film some dishonorable mentions
include friend request kidnap home again
rupture Geo storm 47 meters down and XXX
the return of xander cage to those films
they were truly awful but they weren't
as bad as the next 10 that we're going
to talk about let's begin all of a snow
man sitting through this was terrible it
was so boring and filled with such
potential the cast and the filmmaker
alone the cinematographer everything
about this movie should have been great
and it was one of the worst thrillers
that this year had to offer oh my god
this circle if the Snowman wasn't boring
enough the circle is one of the most
difficult films to sit through again
filled with a lot of potential Emma
Watson and Tom Hanks in the same movie
okay let's see oh nothing's happening
it's a bunch of metaphors about
technology and how dangerous it is this
movies really ahead of its time we've
never seen a film like that before ever
Oh Stanley Kubrick did that in the
sixties whoops
[Music]
I'm sure most of you didn't even see
collide I'm sure most of you don't even
know what that is well I saw it and it
was really fucking bad I hated this film
it was almost a comedy and Ben Kingsley
with his crazy performance sort of kind
of saved certain scenes but for the most
part it was just an action thriller with
no thrills
[Music]
don't hang up was a VOD horror film that
was in a few theaters and I decided to
go to a theater nearby and actually see
it because I liked supporting
independent films especially indie
horror
I think indie horror filmmakers can do
some really great things and most of
them are doing things way better than
mainstream horror filmmakers are in this
case this was a film that had good
intentions but was filled with some of
the worst performances of the year and
some truly awful special effects and a
story that seemed like it was sewn
together really quickly by taking a
bunch of other parts from other films
and mashing them all into one
[Music]
unforgettable is truly unforgettable in
one specific sense that of that you
cannot stop remembering how awful it was
this film is filled to the brim with
Lifetime channel drama it's a big soap
opera movie starring talent that's
proven in the past to be for the most
part better than this material but for
whatever reason decided to make it the
bye bye man I could easily put this film
on my number one because it's just so
completely incompetent in just about
everything about it was a complete
failure but I couldn't because I had so
much fun watching and reviewing this
movie with my buddy the flick pick this
is one of the most fun experiences I had
at the theater all year because we could
barely contain our laughter the death
scenes the stupid wallpaper turning into
something I mean this film had
everything the vibe I man is one of the
best unintentionally funny horror movies
I've seen in a long time
all that being said it is really bad
[Music]
for almost every single movie I've seen
at the theaters in the past few months
they've shown a trailer for the new
Fifty Shades freed or whatever it's
called and I'm dreading going to that
theater because fifty shades darker is
the second in this series to receive an
F and it is well deserved it's one of
the worst stories one of the worst
relationships ever portrayed in film is
barely even good enough as a comedy it's
just atrocious in every way and you can
almost see on the actors faces with
every line they say they're just
cringing and just waiting for their
contracts to be up Resident Evil the
final chapter one can only hope because
this series has proven to be one of the
most incompetent leader ected series and
written ever it completely scrubs the
awesomeness that is the source material
I'm a huge fan of the Resident Evil
games and it goes for this stupid matrix
ripoff sci-fi horrible shaky-cam
bullshit editing action scenes and I
can't stand it and this may have been
the worst in the entire franchise I'll
be honest I almost put Flatliners at
number one because this is hands-down
one of the most boring films I have ever
seen I could barely sit through this
movie there was a guy in the theater
literally one other guy theater who got
on his phone every once in a while
because he was apparently bored too and
I said this in my review I was more
entertained by glancing over his phone
screen lighting up every once in a while
than the actual movie that was playing
out in front of me it was this strange
movie that was supposedly going to be a
sequel to the original Flatliners it
even has Kiefer Sutherland in a role but
he's playing a completely different
character instead it was just some
strange retread trying to recapture
whatever the original film had which the
original film isn't even all that good
Flatliners without a doubt is 2017
cinematic nyquil
so of course you guys know what my
number one's going to be how could you
not what other film this year angered me
so much what other film this year the
I truly hate experiencing and even hate
talking about
well that film is of course it's the
emoji movie it's the most sickness
inducing film of the year yeah it's a
throwaway animated movie that maybe kids
will go to what buddy fucking do right
actually as an adult sitting in this
theater filled with children and hearing
them all go ooh when they saw the
YouTube app Oh mommy it's Spotify or
older playing just dance mommy sitting
in that theater with those kids
realizing that the moral of the film
they're all watching was text more often
made me want to find every copy of this
movie and destroy it this is a movie
that isn't just a terrible unfunny
boring concept that should never have
happened it's a film that panders to
children's intelligence and teaches them
lessons they should never learn and if
you ever thought even for a second that
I was remotely exaggerating my hatred
for this movie well then I have this to
say
[Music]
back when the emoji movie came out I
almost wanted to go to a second showing
of it just to sit in the middle of the
theater and laugh without smiling as
annoying as I possibly could just sit
there every time meh said some stupid
thing and go well there you have it
those are my least favorite movies of
2017 guys thank you so much for watching
another year in film with me it's been
great talking about some mostly pretty
good movies there's always some stinkers
but it was also nice to vent it's fun to
make these videos guys thank you so much
for watching my videos and I really
appreciate it as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]